Nick Cannon now has 11 children with six
women and a 12th child on the way and
there was a column in the daily Wire by
Joe curl and it said Nick Cannon I think
it was by Joe and said Nick Cannon is
the worst role model ever and I have to
correct Joe a little bit here I agree
Nick Cannon is a terrible role model
but he's not the worst role model ever
to Nick Cannon's Credit in our abortive
culture
at least he lets his children live
I mean that sincerely
we live in a culture that at least
before the Dobb's decision killed 850
000 babies a year
so Nick Cannon is being very
irresponsible and there's no way that he
can be a proper father to all of these
children and these children are not all
going to grow up in the home with Nick
Cannon and they're going to miss out on
a lot of daddy time and they're going to
have a very skewed understanding of
marriage and the relations between men
and women that's all true that's really
unfortunate
at least he didn't kill him
Nick Cannon is more responsible than
many many parents out there today
who drive to the Planned Parenthood and
kill their kids
many many parents you think in New York
especially when we're talking about
black babies more black babies are are
aborted in New York than born
so you want to knock Nick Cannon
absolutely yeah the guy he really needs
to shape up he needs to act like a man
he needs to stop uh disrespecting the
institution of marriage and he needs to
be a better father yeah that's true
at least he didn't kill them right now
head on over to establishtitles.com
Knowles established titles is your
opportunity to earn the title of Lord or
lady and gain the respect you deserve
all you need is a one square foot plot
of land in Scotland okay I had this
problem where I thought I'm just not
getting the respect that is due to me
okay people when they come up to me
they'd say hey Michael
hey Mr note mister
I want to be referred to as a lard or a
lord okay there is this uh wonderful
Scottish custom where landowners are
referred to as Lords and Ladies well in
your title pack you will be bestowed
with at least one square foot of
dedicated land on a private estate in
edelston Scotland plus an official
certificate with a Crest your
certificate features a unique plot
Number with which you can see the exact
location of your land title packs from
established titles are a fun and unique
gift for any occasion there are a couple
packs because you don't want to let your
wife you know just be some strumpet
you're a Lord and then she's just some
chick on the street so you want her to
be a lady as well established titles
told me that the first 200 people to
purchase a title pack using my exclusive
link will receive a plot within walking
distance of mine depending on how many
of you want to become a lord or a lady
we can begin to build our own kingdom
established titles is actually running a
massive sale right now and if you use
code Knowles at checkout you will get an
additional 10 off go to
establishtitles.com Knowles to get your
gifts now and help support the channel
the Nick Cannon stuff by the way
is
becoming mainstream I mean you're you're
now seeing report after report weird
social media video after weird social
media video
about how marriage is
are giving way in a culture that has
abandoned the meaning of marriage
to polycules
Okay so
this is our polycule
this is everybody okay and we also have
two kids but we don't show them on tick
tock
me and Kyle have been together for eight
years been probably the whole time okay
me and Kyle are in a Triad with kit
we
have been together three of us for three
years we have one child together
and she's five
oh we don't show the kids on Tick Tock
though
so
me and Kyle
and me Kyle and kit were attracted okay
okay
now
me and Sam
and kit
and Katie
met around the same time I started
dating Sam and kit started dating Katie
around the same time my dogs are going
crazy
Okay so
I started dating Sam kit started in
Katie and then
um just about a little over a month ago
we moved everyone in together so
everyone lives in the same house now we
all live together
it would be funny
except for the kids the kids thing makes
it not funny
because it this is how this poor kid is
going to grow up multiple kids I guess
imagine that someday even when the kid
has grown up hey how'd your parents meet
how much how much time do you have
well kit met Kitty and and then Kitty
met Davey and then Davey had a
relationship with Philip and then
that's not the sort of thing you want to
be telling your grandkids that's not a
dignified way to live
it's weirder than the Nick Cannon stuff
frankly Nick Cannon is just pretending
that he's some you know Old Testament
Wayward King who's got a harem of women
multiple wives and
they're all obviously aware of one
another it's not good but it's got It's
a little bit more traditional than this
nonsense and by the way Society broadly
condemns what Nick Cannon is doing but
the society is largely encouraging what
these weirdos are doing because these
weirdos are able to wrap their their
perversions and their base desires up in
the rainbow flag Nick Cannon can't do
that Nick Cannon in many ways seems just
like an emblem of the patriarchy whereas
these people when they say yeah I'm
dating three people in my household and
I've got a kid with one of them and then
the other one's got a kid with this one
and then we got three dudes over there
in the corner oh Love Is Love Love Is
Love don't don't yuck my yum you know
come on man we're all just be tolerant
just be understanding and then in our
insane culture we've got to say wow
you're right I just hadn't thought about
it that way you're right you're in a
polycule man that's cool and by the way
when we take away the meaning of
marriage
what is to say that marriage won't soon
come to Define this there's no limiting
principle on it whatsoever
I've got I've got the language here by
the way from the marriage bill
language the marriage bill will
allegedly protect all religious liberty
and conscious protections under the
Constitution or federal law
and it will confirm that non-profit
religious organizations will not be
required to provide services facilities
or Goods for the solemnization or
celebration of a marriage okay now
notice that right here by the way I say
a non-profit religious organization will
not be required to get along with with
the new definition of marriage with gay
marriage what about businesses they're
throwing uh poor Jack Phillips under the
bus who throwing masterpiece cake shop
under the bus they're saying private
companies and private artists will have
to participate in gay marriages even if
it violates their religious beliefs
religious Christians and Jews and
Muslims you're going to have to
participate in gay marriages now if you
don't want us to take your business away
from you
and then it says guarantees that this
bill may not be used to deny or alter
any benefit Rider status to any person
or entity blah blah blah blah blah oh
and then oh here we go
it makes clear that the bill does not
require or authorize the federal
government to recognize polygamous
marriages
yet
why not first of all how pathetic is
this this is what conservatism means now
hey look
I'm I'm totally fine with radically
redefining the Bedrock social
institution uh
but polygamy's too far that's where I
draw the line okay I'm listen I'm a
conservative I'm going to draw the line
listen I'm totally fine with normalizing
all sorts of sexual deviancy but I draw
the line at pedophilia for kids under
eight
okay well listen I'm a conservative I
draw the line at kids under seven
they've already done this with the sex
surgery it used to be no weird
transgender surgery because that's
disordered and we don't encourage people
to mutilate themselves now it's okay but
not until they turn 18. okay but not
until they turn 16. okay but not until
they turn 12. now the best law on this
in the country is from Ron DeSantis in
Florida and it says you can't trans the
kids until third grade
up up until third grade so starting in
fourth grade that's when they can be
indoctrinated into LGBT and by the way
it's the best law in the country
this is the most conservative law we've
got
and they've actually okay but only once
you turn nine
I said my friend Vivek ramaswamy dubbed
it the wait till eight bill
and that's where it's going so and
there's no reason to believe that this
marriage law will actually
prohibit polygamy for very long because
why would it
the argument for the real meaning of
marriage is that marriage is in its very
nature the union of one man and one
woman for the sake of the generation and
education of children that's just what
it is ontologically that's what it is
the argument for redefining marriage is
the vislove man and Anthony Kennedy is
there on Supreme Court he's like
we got a right to intimacy
you know man and it's like this is the
dawning of the age of Aquarius right so
if that's the argument for it it's just
love is love and Whoever likes each
other they can just say that they're
married how on Earth could you possibly
prohibit polygamy from that definition
I would violate the the very premise of
the redefinition
so get get ready for a polycule near you
today we will be discovering all sorts
of new genders on tick tock
I usually interview people on on
Tuesdays but you know listen today today
is all about Trump's announcement we're
going to be talking later on for that so
I figured we needed to mix it up a
little bit get some open our minds on
these questions of gender the rest of
the show continues now you don't want to
miss it if you're not a member click the
link in the description
and join us
[Music]
[Music]